Всего одна привычка, которая изменит
вашу жизнь на до и после. Я называю эту
привычку кайзен час. Почему кайзен и
почему час? Дело в том, что кайзен - это
японская философия непрерывного
совершенствования. То есть, э, это
философия, при котором люди, процессы
бизнеса всё время должны
совершенствоваться. А почему час? Потому
что именно этот час я посвящаю этому
делу. Каждое утро я просыпаюсь и после
занятия, а ходьбой я сажусь за казнен
час. Те улучшение в своей жизни, которые
я получаю, они происходят не благодаря
тем действиям, которые я делаю в течение
дня, а больше благодаря тому, что я, э,
какие решения принимаю в течение этого
кайзного часа. Решения, принятые в
течение этого кайз часа, имеют
мультипликативный мультиплицирующий
эффект. Я бы ещё называю это
эффект сложных процентов, когда эффект с
годами только накапливается. Почему это
происходит? Потому что во время этого
часа я задаю себе вопросы: что мне нужно
улучшить? Что мне нужно сделать? Что мне
нужно сделать так, чтобы делать что-то
эффективнее? Что мне нужно сделать
что-то, чтобы делать это с меньшими
затратами, с меньшей энергией, с тратить
на это меньше времени? что мне нужно
автоматизировать, что мне нужно
делегировать, а-а что мне там нужно
подправить, что новое изучить и так
далее. То есть этот час, в течение
которого я размышляю только об
эффективности своей деятельности,
которой я буду заниматься в остальное
время. И почему даёт этот кайз час даёт
такой мультипликативный эффект? Потому
что в это время я пишу свои алгоритмы, я
пишу свои стандарты. Почему важно писать
алгоритмы? Давайте я приведу пример. Вот
представьте, вы лезете на дерево, да? Вы
лезете на дерево, лезете, лезете 15 лет
уже своей жизни, 20 лет своей жизни, а
потом выбрали не ту ветку и бабамс упали
на землю. Всё. Большинство людей
считает, всё, жизнь кончилась, потому
что новых 15-20 лет у них нет, энергия
уже не та, и они не делают второй
попытки. Но когда у вас есть алгоритм,
прописанный, как лезть на это дерево и
не ошибаться, не уходить в тупиковой
ветви, вы понимаете, что теперь повтор
этого пути займёт у вас гораздо меньше
времени. Ну, года два. И таким образом
вы через 2 года будете опять в той же
точке, с которой сорвались. Поэтому я
шучу и часто называю, а, успешного
человека. Это тот человек, который
ежедневно поедает события, а сзади
выпускает ресурсы. То есть, если вы не
научились конвертировать события,
которые с вами происходят в ресурсы, то
вы неэффективны. А в чём могут
выражаться ресурсы? Например, я
познакомился с одним человеком и провёл
встречу как попало, не зарядил его. Что
произойдёт? Я просто потратил час
времени и всё. А если я с этим человеком
поговорил от души, с душой, а говорил о
конкретных проектах, не о политике, там,
не о тех вещах, которые вне моего
контроля, а о конкретных о конкретном
проекте, о конкретных действиях и так
далее, либо м замотивировал его, то, что
в этот момент произошло? Я приобрёл
связи. Я приобрёл связи, потому что а-а
у меня появился человек, который теперь
будет думать о том, как бы что-то
сделать с Маргланом, либо я что-то делаю
и совершил ошибку. Это событие со мной
произошло. Как это превратить в ресурс?
Я прописываю алгоритм, что нужно делать
и или что не нужно делать, чтобы эта
ошибка не повторилась. Алгоритм является
ресурсом. Почему алгоритм является
ресурсом? Потому что алгоритм экономит
мне время в будущем. Мне не надо будет
тратить свои ресурсы на совершение такой
же ошибки. В этой жизни не надо бояться
совершать ошибок, но надо бояться
совершать два типа ошибок. Первый тип -
это ошибки с необратимыми последствиями.
[музыка]
И второй тип ошибок - это ошибки,
которые постоянно повторяются. Все эти
моменты можно избежать, если у вас есть
кайзн час, в течение которого вы
оттачиваете свою эффективность.
Предположим на другом примере. Если вы
дровосек, то 24х7 сутками рубить лес -
это не самый эффективный путь. А если вы
каждый день будете затрачивать по одному
часу на затачивание топора, то ваша
эффективность вырастет гораздо больше.
Поэтому, э, вот этот кайзн час является
эффектом рычага. Этот час увеличивает
эффективность всех остальных моих
рабочих часов. Если, предположим,
человек работает 8 часов, то потратьте
час на повышение своей эффективности, и
ваши 7 часов будут давать отдачу как 14,
как 20, как 30. Каждый час - это
основной рычаг. Поэтому применяйте в
своей жизни. Это несложно. Выделите
каждое утро 1 час или хотя бы полчаса,
когда вы будете думать только о том, как
оптимизировать свою деятельность. И это,
поверьте мне, принесёт вам большие
плоды, и вы не узнаете свою жизнь. Она
поделится на до и